Hollywood has yet to do these iconic
characters Justice on the big screen
if you asked fans to name the best comic
book villains of all time Dr Victor Von
Doom would definitely appear near the
top of the list a longtime enemy of the
Fantastic Four Doom is one of Marvel's
greatest characters someone who can
present a threat not just to the fore
but to the entire Multiverse in the
comics Doom is a scientist warlock
politician and a true leader among men
his iconic face and body armor hide one
of the most brilliant strategic Minds in
existence and doom has used his brains
to take on and win against Godlike
beings Doom is also not a one note evil
guy but a deeply tragic figure and
someone who's extremely pragmatic always
having a good reason for his most
ruthless actions unfortunately All This
Magnificent complexity and high-minded
villainy has failed to translate to the
big screen in the 2000s era Fantastic
Four movies Doom is just some scientist
guy who ran randomly gets superpowers
tries to attack the four and gets his
butt kicked we see another version of
Doom in the 2015 reboot this time
reimagined as a computer scientist
turned madman who wants to kill off all
of humanity after going insane because
of his interdimensional travels even
actor Toby kebbel admitted his 2015
Incarnation was a misfire saying via
Cinema Blend I truly believe Doom is an
awesome villain and they kind of always
just do something Goofy with it it's a
shame it's a shame it's time to end this
the role of the mysterious siren has
been around since the earliest days of
Cinema she's the woman with the Exotic
clothes and accent who can send men wild
with a single glance she's the woman who
the hero and villain can spend the
entire movie fighting over and one of
the oldest Hollywood sirens is Queen
Cleopatra from Elizabeth Taylor in
1963's Cleopatra to Monica Bellucci in
2002's asterisks and Obelix Mission
Cleopatra most movies depicting the
ancient Queen like to focus on her
overwhelming Beauty this includes the
fact that she was able to seduce not one
but two powerful Roman leaders Julius
Caesar and Mark Anthony but the truth is
claims of her beauty have also been
greatly exaggerated by Hollywood most
depictions of Cleopatra that survive on
coins and as sculptures depict her as a
pretty ordinary looking woman the Greek
historian Plutarch put it rather bluntly
when he wrote for her beauty we are told
was in itself not altogether
incomparable nor such as to strike those
who saw her
it's been speculated that Cleopatra was
able to charm so many men mainly due to
her wit and intelligence rather than her
looks but that angle doesn't fit very
well with a visual medium like Cinema
where it's much easier to show men
falling for a radiantly beautiful
Cleopatra
Frankenstein the lead character of Mary
Shelley's 1818 horror novel Frankenstein
is a brilliant doctor obsessed with
understanding and perfecting a way to
create life and bring back the dead in
the course of his research Dr
Frankenstein builds a monster out of
dead human body parts successfully
reanimating the multi-corp structure and
giving it human intelligence this new
creation is Frankenstein's monster and
he's appeared in many movies over the
decades as a slow-moving fairly
comprehensible simple-minded creature
but that's not how the monster appears
in the original novel in Shelley's Story
the monster is extremely agile fast
powerful and self-reliant he's also
highly intelligent able to speak
multiple languages and strikes a hard
bargain with Frankenstein to furnish him
with a mate so he can start a family the
monster from the novel is not a literal
superhero as in Aaron eckhart's eye
Frankenstein but a cunning articulate
yet deeply tragic figure who both loves
and hates his creator and his own
existence the closest thing to the book
is 1994's Mary Shelley's Frankenstein
Robert De Niro plays a version of the
monster that Hues closely to the novel
but he's distinctly more handsome than
his absolutely monstrous looking book
counterpart his intelligence is also
said to be a result of retaining
memories from the brain of the corpses
made out of rather than natural ability
Hollywood has never had a lot of luck
with Pirate characters before Captain
Jack Sparrow came along the only movie
pirate with any significant currency was
Captain Nemo still even calling the
character a pirate does a disservice to
his backstory as laid out by writer
Jules Verne in 20 000 Leagues Under the
Sea and the Mysterious Island in the
books Nemo is the son of an Indian king
who is forced to flee from his home
after the British imperialist army
attacked a scientific Visionary Nemo had
his special submarine the Nautilus built
from parts from all over the world and
he took to roaming the Seven Seas with
his crew all the while Nemo burned with
a hatred for the British Empire and
dreamed of taking revenge against the
foreign Interlopers who'd conquered his
kingdom unfortunately all that complex
backstory is thrown out the window for
the big screen adaptations of Captain
Nemo most film versions of the character
don't even bother making him Indian with
actors James Mason Herbert LOM Patrick
Stewart and Michael Kane playing him in
various capacities Nasir rudenshaw was
the only Indian actor to play Nemo in
the League of Extraordinary Gentlemen
but the submarine Nautilus got more
attention than Nemo in that film you
underestimate the Nautilus
it's no secret that Hollywood is in dire
need of compelling female action heroes
aside from the Stray Sarah Connor or
imperator furiosa the action movie
landscape is largely dominated by large
men with bulging biceps and more guns
than they know what to do with and yet
Hollywood has been sitting on the
perfect female action star all this time
Laura Croft was the protagonist of a
series of action-adventure video games
called Tomb Raider that blew up in
popularity in the late 90s as the name
of the franchise suggests Lara is an
adventuring archaeologist with a
penchant for raiding Tunes she's a
highly skilled combatant escape artist
linguist and detective along with
possessing any other skill the story
needs her to have to win the day it can
be easy to imagine Laura leading her own
movie franchise as a combination of
James Bond and Indiana Jones yet the two
attempts that Hollywood has made to turn
the character into an action movie star
have given mixed results the Angelina
Jolie version of Lara existed in a world
too can't be to be taken seriously
differently the 2018 reboot starring
Alicia vikander aired too much on the
other side taking all the fun out of the
character in its desire to be gritty
meaning that thus far fans are still
waiting for a movie as good as the 2013
Tomb Raider video game
few novels in history have enjoyed the
widespread popularity of the Harry
Potter books the series was a publishing
phenomenon before Hollywood jumped on
the bandwagon churning out eight movies
based on the novels depicting the
Journey of Harry on his quest to defeat
the dreaded Lord Voldemort what made the
franchise so beloved was the host of
fascinating and likable Side characters
most of whom translated well to the big
screen but some weren't so lucky like
Ginny Weasley who in the books is a
fiery funny intelligent character Harry
finds himself falling in love with fans
of the novels remember Ginny as someone
who's unafraid to stand up to bullies
and who speaks her mind to everyone all
the time unfortunately the movies do a
poor job of reflecting those qualities
in Ginny played by Bonnie Wright the
character is a pale shadow of her book
self in the films with hardly any
important lines or scenes to Showcase
her spunky nature Jenny's relationship
with Harry is also a lot more subdued to
the point where you wonder why the two
ever got together given their noticeable
lack of chemistry
if the Joker is the greatest villain
from Batman's Rogues Gallery Lex Luthor
is the equally iconic Arch Enemy to
Superman at least that's the way it
shakes out in the comics despite being
an ordinary mortal the Comic version of
Luthor actually feels like a credible
threat to the Man of Steel in a way that
no other villain from the hero's
mythology does but the movies are a
different story Luthor is frequently
seen in live-action Superman movies but
he rarely comes across as a foreboding
figure the version of Luthor played by
Gene Hackman is way too campy to be
threatening there's little evidence of
the laser focused businessman or
calculating genius from the comics who's
always three steps ahead of his enemies
Kevin Spacey could have brought those
qualities to the character in Superman
Returns but he instead chose to follow
Hackman's lead in making Luthor a
hackneyed Bond villain then came Jesse
eisenberg's take on Lex Luthor in the
dceu and fans were left scratching their
heads wondering what to make of a
character Eisenberg plays Luthor as a
Twitchy nervy Millennial with a
high-pitched voice somehow managing to
seem even less threatening than
Hackman's version of the character so
far the closest thing to a live-action
version of Luthor from the comics was
seen on the TV show Smallville where
Michael Rosenbaum managed to add great
depth and intelligence to the role
Batman is one of the most popular
superheroes in history yet despite the
Caped Crusader being such a recognizable
superhero few of his supporting
castmates from the comics have been big
hits on the big screen the thing is
Batman has a good number of superhero
allies in the comics who rarely get a
mention in the movies one of his most
important allies is Barbara Gordon AKA
Batgirl daughter of Commissioner James
Gordon aside from being a noble hero in
her own right Barbara has one of the
most tragic character arcs in the comics
when she gets attacked by The Joker and
is permanently confined to a wheelchair
refusing to give up Barbara finds a
second life as the Cyber hacker
vigilante Oracle unfortunately all this
backstory has never been shown on the
big screen Batman and Robin reimagined
Barbara with Alicia Silverstone as the
niece of Batman's butler who likes
street racing and stumbles into becoming
Batgirl after having the costume handed
to her suit me up Uncle Alfred
the Leslie Grace Batgirl movie was
canceled before it could ever see the
light of day and there doesn't seem to
be any plan to include Barbara in the
two separate Batman franchises currently
in development under Matt Reeves and
Todd Phillips
[Music]